apple's new macbook pros have taken the  world by storm earning various world's  best trophies for everything from the  world's best laptop speakers and  displays all the way to the world's  fastest laptop cpu performance but then  intel's new i9  hk chip pulled ahead of the m1 max by  almost 500 points in the multi-core test  with that said don't think that intel  just swooped in and obliterated apple's  new m1 max ship if we convert those  leaked benchmarks into performance per  watt metrics the m1 max takes the clear  win but then we got some incredibly  impressive leaked cinebench r23  benchmark numbers for the lower end  alder lake i7 12700h  basically proving that multiple alder  lake chips are going to be outperforming  the 10 core m1 pro and max by a huge  margin now the only question that  remains is real world performance in  real productivity workloads